il pourrait y avoir une centaine de
morts c'est la tragédie la plus
meurtrière depuis 10 ans en mer
Méditerranée dans la nuit du mardi 13 au
mercredi 14 juin une embarcation
transportant entre 600 et 700 migrants a
fait naufrage au large du village de
Pilos dans le Péloponnèse le moteur
s'est arrêté l'embarcation à chavirer
d'un coup nous le suivions pour voir sa
trajectoire et d'un coup tout s'est
accéléré mercredi 79 corps avait déjà
été repêché plus de 100 personnes ont
été secourues les blessés étant
transféré à l'hôpital de Kalamata
certains dans un état d'extrême urgence
mais les autorités craignent de voir le
bilan explosé sur les centaines de
passagers portés disparus aucun n'était
équipé d'un gilet de sauvetage comme le
rapporte la télévision publique
ert le bateau de pêche transportant les
migrants en quête d'Europe était parti
mardi du port de Tobrouk en Libye la
plupart étaient originaire de Siri du
Pakistan ou d'Égypte selon les
garde-côtes grecques le navire avait été
repéré dans l'après-midi par un avion de
Frontex l'agent européenne de
surveillance des frontières mais les
migrants à bord aurait refusé toute
selon les autorités portuaires grecques
l'ONG alarm phone affirme avoir reçu un
premier appel de détresse à 14h17
plusieurs appels seront reçus dans les
heures suivantes plusieurs passagers ont
affirmé que le capitaine a quitté
l'embarcation que le navire est
surchargé et qu'il tangent d'un bord à
l'autre alerté dès 16h53 les autorités
grecques ont immédiatement lancé une
opération de sauvetage à grande échelle
en plus des patrouilleurs de la police
portuaire une frégate de la marine de
guerre grecque un avion et un
hélicoptère de l'armée de l'air ainsi
que 6 bateaux qui naviguaient dans la
zone ont été mobilisés mais au fil des
heures l'espoir de retrouver des
survivants s'épuisent depuis le début de
l'année 44 personnes sont mortes noyées
en Méditerranée orientale d'après
l'Organisation Internationale des
migrations l'an dernier le nombre de
personnes ayant ainsi péri s'est élevé à
jusqu'à présent les réfugiés prenaient
la route de la Turquie en direction des
îles grecques au nord de l'egers mais
les passeurs savent que la politique
migratoire a pris un autre tournant ces
dernières années
il est très difficile de passer par nos
îles et ses exilés préfèrent donc se
rendre en Libye pour atteindre l'Italie
cette nouvelle tragédie a également
secoué la classe politique grecque en
campagne électorale à 10 jours du
scrutin national le 25 juin prochain les
candidats de l'opposition ont multiplié
les critiques à l'encontre du
gouvernement conservateur de Kyriacos
Mitsotakis qui a durci la politique
migratoire menant selon eux à des drames
de grande ampleur et transformant la
Méditerranée en cimetière d’âmes face à
cette tragédie inédite trois jours de
deuil ont été décrétés dans le pays